we were like we're not having kids until
we can pay for kids right cuz we had so
many friends in standup like even Bert
like he's one of those guys has a kid is
like a feature act making $100 a you
know a show and I was like uh-uh and I
wanted kids and Christina was like we're
going to have kids on what we make this
is crazy I didn't want to be at the
level I was at at the time which is a
feature Act of making a $100 a show when
you have a kid your immediate thing is
like well I'm no longer cool cuz you're
like drinking partying then you go if I
have a kid am I going to be like a dad
comic who's like diapers the other thing
that happens you go into like Hunter
Gathering hustle mode where it's like a
drive that you didn't know even existed
in you yeah I had a guy asked me one
time do you have kids and he's like a
middle eastern guy and I said no dude I
still got a lot of stuff I want to do
with my life you know I want to make
money and this and that and he was so
shocked and he's like in the Middle
Eastern culture the more kids you have
the more money you make it's a good omen
yeah